Hello world.
It's Saroj and I'm excited to announce
that school of Ai is launching a research
lab thanks to Google cloud.
We're going to offer 10 wizards,
1000 US dollars in cloud credits to
pursue some exciting research directions.
There'll be our fall 2018 fellows.
Each of them will receive personalized
mentoring ship from one of our
experienced advisers to help
them along their journey.
We'd like to grow the amateur research
community that means wizards from around
the world who aren't necessarily
a part of academia or industry.
We believe that by enabling them to do
research with a complete pipeline of
resources,
from funding to mentorship to helping
them submit their work to relevant
outlets, the entire AI community
will benefit. So here's the plan.
We've got some research directions that
we think are particularly exciting,
including metal learning or learning
to learn quantum machine learning,
one shot learning or learning from
small datasets and deep reinforcement
learning.
But these are all suggestions.
All 10 selected applicants will be able
to choose the research direction of
their choice.
With one caveat,
it has to be applied to
one of the United Nations,
17 sustainable development goals.
Current AI technology accessible to
anyone with an internet connection allows
ordinary people to create solutions to
accelerate the progress of each of these
school of AI research is applied research.
We make scientific discoveries
with specific real world
use cases in mind and we
need a new standard for how these
papers are presented. To that end,
I've assisted to deep
reinforcement learning engineers,
Laura Gracer and Kang while Lune and
helping build out a framework for deep
reinforcement learning
research called SLM lab.
It's design was guided by four
principles, modularity, simplicity,
analytical clarity,
and crucially reproducibility.
We've got several baseline reinforcement
learning algorithms implemented and
more to come.
SLM lab is an easy way to get started
with deep reinforcement learning research.
You can just build on top of an existing
algorithm and benchmark the results.
All the algorithms relevant environments
and testing tools are included in a
single repository.
We have both a static and
dynamic version of our paper.
The static version is a pdf,
like all papers are,
but the dynamic version
is a Jupiter notebook.
We've hosted it on Google Colab,
which means that anyone who reads the
paper can also view the results and a demo
of SLM lab by running code
themselves in their browser.
No dependencies necessary.
We want this to serve as an example,
school of AI researchers should create
both a static and a dynamic version of
their research paper.
So I hope you're hyped.
You'll find a link to the
application in the video description.
We'll take one week to choose
applications and announced them publicly.
So if you're interested,
hurry up and sign up now.